we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p received a
number of voicemails and emails related
to my appendicitis it was great to hear
from the eggman take a listen to this hi
i'm just calling to see if dave is
feeling better I'm worried about him
hoping you out of the hospital soon and
hoping you recover quickly hello brother
Shalom Eggman yes I was out of the
hospital within a couple of hours of the
procedure I am feeling significantly
better not a hundred percent I'm told it
can take even sometimes up to two weeks
to be back to 100% but working on it
every day I also got some people
believed they thought people there are
people now who think that the Bernie
Sanders thing is a distraction and that
the producer Pat thing is a distraction
take a listen to this David this is
Ralphie from Tallahassee just gonna
leave you a message my concern is this
appendicitis thing is it just the
distraction yeah you're spot on it's
it's absolutely 110% merely a
distraction no but in all seriousness
thanks to everybody who reached out on
Twitter email Instagram Facebook I heard
from a ton of people and I really do
appreciate it and as part of my recovery
I am NOT doing the bonus show today so
producer Pat is going to have a
fantastic bonus show for you today two
ways to access it become a member at
join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show